when we made our decision in December of
2017 I kept track of some of those
predictions you're going to have to pay
$5 per tweet you're not going to be
allowed to post on Instagram one of my
favorites the Senate Democratic caucus
Twitter account said the internet will
work one word at a time or one of my
favorites this is the end of the
Internet as we know it about a year and
a half ago or so and net neutrality
disappeared if you were paying attention
to the sort of mainstream take on it
this was it
World War three was starting the
audience over nobody was going to get
video everybody was going to be
throttled you know corporations we're
gonna take over here we are it's amazing
so can you just all right can you
absolutely just for the people that
really want like the cleanest clearest
explanation so we can clip this purse
perfectly what was that neutrality and
what actually happened so net neutrality
involves the basic question of how if at
all should the FCC treat Internet access
should it regulate it under what is
called title 2 which was the 1930s
regulations that were developed to
regulate Ma Bell the old telephone
monopoly or should regulate the Internet
under title 1 the more market-based
approach that governed the internet from
1996 until 2015 my view is the
market-based approach service very well
we got to 1.5 trillion dollars of
network investment companies like some
of those go that we've mentioned
becoming giants from startups and
consumers benefiting from all that
innovation and at the end of the day I
look at the evidence that's in the
record when we made our decision in
December of 2017 I kept track of some of
those predictions you're going to have
to pay $5 per tweet you're not going to
be allowed to post on Instagram one of
my favorites the Senate Democratic
caucus Twitter account said the internet
will work one word at a time or one of
my favorites this is the end of the
Internet as we know it well fast forward
to now internet speeds in the United
States on average are up over 50%
network investment in 2018 was up 3
billion dollars the second and
consecutive increase more fiber was
deployed in 2018 than in any year since
they've been keeping records and venture
capital funding startups has set a
record in 2018 one wouldn't expect that
if these Internet service providers were
in fact acting as a gatekeeper choking
off in
and so to those critics out there I
would say the record is clear the
Internet is open and more open than ever
and thanks to our decision more people
than ever before faster than ever before
can hate tweet their favorite SEC
chairman and so I think it's a testament
to our success right so you got an
unbelievable about coming my god during
that time yeah no kidding was that that
might have led you to want to regulate
some of this a little bit more stuck
with your ideals yeah no I did it there
was a lot of pressure the on the other
side no question about it and a personal
threats from made against me and my
family and even the agency itself there
are people in jail today for threatening
my family and the agency and so but at
the end of the day I really have the
conviction that we were doing the right
thing and you know I've got a I quote by
my computer and I see it every single
day when I power up it is from Churchill
back in the 20s and said you hear this
young men and women and proclaim it far
and wide the earth is yours and the
fullness thereof be kind but be fierce
you are needed now more than ever before
take up the mantle of change for now is
your time and I know it sounds cheesy
but I really do try to erase that ethos
that you've got to you've got to know
what you believe and you've got to
execute on that belief to the best of
your ability and take the arrows that
come with it is it going to be popular
always no not at all I may understand
that a lot of people still are angry
about this decision but at the end of
the day I've got the long term in mind
and the long term is one in which the
digital divide closes everyone's
connected to the Internet the Internet
is free and open and that's the vision
that we're gonna continue to execute do
you think just to sort of give the
people that wanted to keep net
neutrality in place to give the devil is
do let's say do you think that it's just
a fundamental misunderstanding of what
companies do I mean they the fear seem
to be that if you if you don't regulate
them in this way that you know one
company will slow down Netflix and the
other one will speed up their own
broadband service and all these things
and there is some light there's some
like initial thought that kind of makes
sense they're like you would want to
hurt your competitors if you're in
several businesses and you'd want to
help your partners but that that's not
really how competition works and I guess
everything that you just laid out is
sort of proof of that I mean yeah you
think that they just sort of
fundamentally misunderstand
and economics or something like that I
think I understand the concerns they
might have in the abstract but the two
things I always try to emphasize to LA
those concerns are number one I support
Congress putting on the page in the
modern era what the rules of the road
should be I mean I would it's a one-page
bill honestly the Congress gonna pass
tomorrow no blocking of lawful content
on the internet no throttling and lawful
content no any competitive paid
prioritization transparency make sure
every Internet service provider
documents all its business and network
management practices for everyone to see
I've just outlined a 99% supportable
bill but that's never going to happen
because no such thing is a one-page
paper
oh come on you got ad in what like 5,000
more pages all the wearables that have
something to do with farming exactly but
this is a very simple bill that I would
support I think most members of Congress
would support but the political impulses
from those who really rapidly want
heavy-handed regulation they're never
going to allow that to happen the second
thing I emphasize is look Andy antitrust
and competition law has long been a very
steadfast protector for of competition
in this area the FTC and the Department
of Justice in particular the internet
didn't die from 1996 to 2015 when we had
this exact same framework to the
contrary it thrived with the
market-based approach and just think
about what the internet would have been
if we treated it like Ma Bell you would
have an internet that was just as
reliable as Amtrak as popular as the
post office as efficient as the DMV that
is the model that some people want to
return to and to me that's not good
enough American consumers deserve better
than that
have you I'm sure you've heard about
this sort of platform verse publisher
yeah that's about the stupidest question
I've ever asked them going to go out on
a limb and assume you've heard about
this debate so for me as a guy that
wants as little regulation as possible
so I totally hear your your philosophy
on this the platform versus publisher
one is starting to make sense to me this
is a place where I could start seeing a
need for regulation because if you're
just a platform then you should you
should have to do all the things that
you want in your one but you know your
one pager but if you're a publisher then
you have those extra responsibilities
yet in a weird way the platform say
Twitter YouTube Facebook are behave
like publishers and not platforms how
complex is all of this to gun pack it's
it's exceptionally complex and one of
the fascinating things to watch from my
vantage point is on Capitol Hill you're
now seeing Republicans and Democrats
openly wondering should we change the
laws sheila's hold hearings to examine
how we should change the laws to
accommodate this new understanding and
it's everything that seems to be up for
grabs right now and I'm not sure how
it's going to play out but that debate
of platform versus publisher is
something that I think was pretty much
unthinkable just five years ago so I'm
not sure where it's going to go but
we're certainly watching it do you think
it's possible that there are certain
things that the government is just no
longer equipped to handle like that the
power and the amount of information the
amount of technology that Google let's
say controls right now is so awesome and
unprecedented that the idea that a
government Regulatory Commission could
actually harness it fully understand it
and and fully guide it in the right way
that that almost is impossible that's a
really quick thing to think about I
suppose yeah but I mean do you think
that is possible that these companies
have grown in ways like the amount of
power that Google has is way more than
MA Bell had in 1930 and and government
obviously changes much slower than a
technology company Canada let's make it
a question I think I mean I have to
think about it a little deeper I would
say it at first cut I do think the tools
of antitrust and competition law are
fairly well suited to deal with
companies that may have market power and
these are well you know the standard
oils of yesteryear are could just as
easily that framework it just as easily
applied to the tech giants of today and
to evaluate whether or not they are
posing an anti-competitive threat what I
would say is the central problem we
haven't yet wrestled with is that the
pace of technological innovation is
quickening if anything and we're now
rapidly dealing with and not just laws
that are out of date but a Congress that
in an regulatory structure that isn't
equipped to deal nimbly with some of the
challenges to give you one example
official recognition technology I mean
you're now seeing a lot of people
wondering well should we ban or shall we
regulate facial recognition technology
how does it work or cryptocurrency is I
use the regulator's struggling with
should we think about this is that
another financial instrument that we
should regulate under the old laws or
should we just come up with something
new and across all of these different
sectors the pace is so fast that by the
time we even understand what it is it's
just almost too late to pass regulations
because the marketplace has moved beyond
it so I think that is one of the central
problems that we haven't yet grappled
with yeah is the other part just that
administration's change pretty quickly
yeah we don't know who the president's
going to be in about a year and a half
from now we really don't and the next
person could come in and is your term is
that just on the the decision of the
President or it is no interior oh so I'm
as like every chairman is a commissioner
so I have a commissioner term that ends
in 2022
and but by law the president has to
designate whoever the Chairman as any
given point in time so so yeah I do I
have a term that runs independent of the
presidential administration that happens
to be in power but technically the next
president could just like you I can take
you out of that term exactly so how much
of your consideration has to do with
just the political realities to me zero
one of the great things about being an
independent agency is that we make the
decision that we think is the right one
and that generally speaking our
initiatives have been nonpartisan in
nature I mean to me at least getting
broadband to rural Americans and tribal
Americans it's not a Republican issue or
democratic issue just an American issue
getting people with disabilities access
to technology helping people and
hurricane ravaged areas it's not a
partisan issue as well and 5g is the
national imperative so a lot of these
things are actually bipartisan in nature
or nonpartisan I would say and so to me
at least that's how I've tried to
embrace the job and the other thing that
goes unremarked in Washington at least
as far as we can tell I'm the first
chairman in history ever to ask each one
of the commissioners Republican and
Democrat to take leadership to speak for
the agency on an issue of importance
traditionally the Chairman essentially
hogs all the responsibility for himself
or herself but I've tried to delegate a
lot of that to make sure that all of
them feel empowered that's good for them
but it's also good for the agency to
show that look we're not a political
agency that rises or Falls based on
where the political winds may happen to
take us if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell